[Music]
folks it's official we are entering the
age of enlightenment my friend a true
feminist in the best sense of the word
and a fearless defender of free speech
christina hoff sommers was invited to
speak at Lewis and Clark law school this
week here's what happened when she began
hurting aside the creepiness of the
clone like repetitive chanting from the
protesters their use of free speech
actually isn't a use of free speech at
all while of course they have the right
to protest your right to exercise your
free speech doesn't come at the expense
of someone else's right to exercise
theirs so what this means is yes you can
peacefully protest outside of event you
can silently protest inside of an event
you can hold all the signs you want and
you can encourage others to join your
cause you cannot however use your
freedoms to trample on the freedoms of
others this chanting which again took
place before christina had even begun to
speak reminded me of when i was at UCLA
with my lowly innopolis about two years
ago
protesters screamed spit through garbage
cans pulled fire alarms and even called
in bomb threats before we even took the
stage perhaps most egregiously though
was the group of students who linked
arms to create a human wall to stop us
and other viewers from even going inside
the venue itself apparently they aren't
against walls they just don't like
Trump's wall Cristina's talk continued
through the chanting and the protesters
then broke out in song quite a catchy
tune wouldn't you say
of course christina hoff sommers isn't a
fascist at all she's just an old school
liberal who dare challenge modern day
leftism ironically these people so keen
on fighting the fake fascism in their
minds don't understand that they
themselves are the ones who are actually
using fascist tactics of silencing and
drowning out their opponents until there
is no opposition remaining at all but if
you're still confused here's a simple
definition of fascism fascism is a form
of radical authoritarian nationalism
characterized by dictatorial power
forcible suppression of opposition and
control of industry and commerce which
came to prominence in early 20th century
Europe do you think that christina hoff
sommers is for dictatorial power is she
for forcible suppression of opposition
to top it off she even works at the
American Enterprise Institute which is
against control of Industry and Commerce
now just think for a moment if the ideas
that these students were espousing were
the set of ideas in power they actually
would be for dictatorial control as they
believe their cause is the most just and
their opponents are simply evil how do
you think it would be going for dissent
and opposition in their system perhaps
the most insidious piece of the cultural
Marxism that we see spreading on college
campuses these days is that it is using
the freedoms that our democratic
capitalist society has against itself of
course it would never offer these same
protections to minority voices in the
dystopian future that it would bring
while this event thankfully wasn't
nearly as violent as when Milo went to
UC Berkeley and the school burned down
or when it took $600,000 of security to
ensure that Ben Shapiro could speak
there without threat this display at
Lewis and Clark is just another reminder
of how the backwards thinking of
cultural Marxism is coming for all
dissenters cloaked in the mask of
tolerance and diversity these incidences
are happening all over colleges all over
the country and turning places of higher
learning into places where people are
just getting high on intersectionality
sadly this story really only broke on
right-leaning blogs and was only shared
by the usual suspects who continually
defend freedom of expression as of
recording this I haven't seen any
left-leaning websites that covered it
the reason for this of course is twofold
on one hand when you can win arguments
by silencing your opponents your job is
pretty easy but also and perhaps more
importantly the good actors on the left
which I still believe there are some who
want to call out events like this rarely
do because they know that the same
tactics of smearing and silencing will
eventually be used against them and then
they'll be purged from their former home
just as former guests of mine like Brett
Weinstein Laura Kipnis Lindsey Shepard
and others who dare speak out against
this tyrannical foe diversity movement
the silver lining though of course is
that the more that people like Brett
Laura and others speak out the more room
they give for people like you to do the
exact same in your life and speaking of
Berkeley I'll be there tomorrow Thursday
night hosted by the Berkeley College
Republicans I'll be joined by Heather
McDonald and Steve Simpson
we'll be live-streaming the event right
here at youtube.com slash Rubin report
at 8:00 p.m. Pacific time come join us
and ask us as many hard questions in the
Q&A at the end as you'd like I ask only
one thing of you which is that if you
sing please make it a little snappier
than what we just heard a cover of
journey Fleetwood
or even Frank Sinatra would be
preferable
[Music]
you